Bước lại sức này được sách định thấp hơn 2 phần chăm 4 năm sau bối lại cho bay chung và dạy hạn mình quân của muốn đơn hàng thứ mạnh cho nước.
A gui vanh BIDV, Việt có bành và biệt tìm bành trong năm năm đầu bay vốn trong buổi nằm tiếp theo lại sức bay ám dùng là bay phần năm.
Thấp hơn 1 liêm phần chăm sau biến quân của nó biết phó thực tế từ đầu đáp biệt đây, một số nước hàng đã cho tăng lại sức cho bay lời trẻ dưới 3 mi lắm tuổi, mua nhở xang hội.
Vì thì bành tăng lên sống về 1 phần chăm 1 năm, hay vì công phát ngám dùng sống về 3 phần chăm.
Chắc vì đó, có ai bay u đã ít năm về năm phần chăm kì hạn mang năm, dạy chung về trẻ 1 giả trình kai từ quý một năm ngày gian cuộc trả bị lắm cũng bị dừng trình kai và quý năm.
Sù vấn tăng lại cho bay được nhiều chuyên gia dự báo từ trước, trong bối cảnh lại sức tiếp kiện có suy lưỡng đi lên.
Tụ trước sẽ thẳng tín dạm BIS, nói tình cho biết, lại sức bay mua nhà bình quân năm nay có thể tăng thêm 3 đến 1 phần chăm sau với cùng ki,
sau mặt bằng lại sức khuy động tăng và tính dụng mất động sản bị sức trật.
Nếu quyết khách cho chủ đầu tư gió bốn vào nhà sáng hội,
quý tháng trước, gân hàng nhạm lức cho phép các nhà bằng thương mại không về tính phần tăng thêm.
Khi cho bay phần khúc nhờ, nhà khu công nghiệp và khu trí sách vào tính dụng mất động sản.
Chế thể trường chiến gân hàng thương mại và đám dụng gỏi tính dụng 1 chăm 20 in tỷ đầu, cho bay u đã ít phát triển nhà sáng hội.
Nhờ, công dân xong tín dụng dạng gân bất rất trăm.
Sau ưu ba năm chiến khai, tý lệ giải ngân bối đả thương năm phẩy nặp ấn chăm,
giù kým mô đặc ký bô tin này đã tắc lên khoảng 1 chăm 4 mila nghiệp tỷ đầu.